and cueto is the giant starter 2-0 a
4-7-5
earned run average his last start came
against the diamondbacks tim lacastro
the center fielder will lead it off at
229 of the year tim lacastro sends one
deep to left center field ted la castro
takes johnny quinn all out of here in
the diamondbacks strike first a late off
home run
and touch them all tim la castro a
leadoff home run to start the ball game
tim's second career home run his other
was last year a chance for rojas now
one nothing after the lead off home run
by tim lecastro
here's a high fly ball deep to center
dubon backing up way out there on the
warning track that'll get calhoun home
peralta tags as well
and it's two nothing diamondbacks our
big eye for josh rojas
and now steven vogt with another runner
in scoring position
vote had a very productive year at the
bat as a giant last year
now fastball struck him out swinging
and the inning is over and the pitcher
for arizona left-hander alex young he's
wanted two with a four five zero
earned run average here's longoria three
for eight lifetime against young with a
home run
two on pitch ground ball to short
ahmed's got it goes to rojas for one and
then on to first run indian ending
double play
the six of the year that longoria has
rolled into and young gets out of it
with the double play ball so two outs
here's dubai
duvan in the series
is four for eight
had two hits in the ball game last night
drove in a run
right-handed hitter the first one here
is down to first nice play by lamb gets
up and gives de young at the bag for the
out to the inning
jacob took a hit away there on a run on
a ball down the line hit by duvan
chadwick trump leading off for the
giants in the bottom of the third two
nothing arizona
trump it's a high fly ball to the left
on the move is peralta
out of here
it's been a while for chadwick trump
he came into that at-bat two for his
last 29. how do you do
up over the left center field wall
chadwick trump has hit his third big
league home run
and the jackets are on the board it's
2-1 diamondbacks
here's slater who bounced out to
nick ahmed at short in the first
2-2 pitch that's popped up
playable
into right center and going back is jay
and makes a catch
john jay in right center field
uh going over along with la castro and
it was jay who made the catch as he
tumbled to the ground one out
le castro is homered and fly to right
field
tim let off the ball game with his
second kerr home run his first ever
leading off the ball game
there's a bunny pushes it and flores is
coming home and they got him
nice play that is his only play
well done by wilmer flores the castro
bunning it
a safety squeeze and
ahmed breaking down the line floor is
charged aggressively and made a good
feed to chadwick trump
to get the out at the plate
peralta has singled and struck out
against cueto there go the runners the
pitch is swung out and missed a low
changeup he struck him out and cueto
wriggles off the hook they've got
the bases loaded with two outs
john jay has
not been called back he is going to hit
there go the runners the pitch swung on
and blooped into shallow left field
rough coming in into a slide and he
makes the catch
and the inning is over
that was close
solano who is two for two of the double
and a single
here's solano he swings and he hits a
high drive deep into left field way back
there still going adios
it's a two run homer for solano that has
turned this game around
suddenly the giants have gone ahead
three to two
and it's the third hit of the afternoon
for solano
that's his third home run this year and
now here's robertson
who has flied out to right center and
struck out
the 3-1
from guerra with two outs and two
runners on
and there's a tamper too short ahmed
scott it has to go to first they get
robertson
two in the inning but the giants strike
for a pair
they do so on the two on omar off the
bound of salado we head to the seventh
three two giants
two outs now and here is escobar here it
comes escobar
takes strike three called fastball
and he and garcia sort of stare at one
another as they walk off the field i
don't know what was going on there
brandon belts gonna come off the bench
and bad for trump
belt drives one to right hit well
it is out of here
and he's got himself a pinch hit home
run
and it doesn't make its way to the water
because it hit a railing and bounced
back on the field but brandon belt has
hit a home run as a pinch hitter
gabe kepler's move pays off big time his
seventh home run of the year
his extraordinary hot streak continues
it's four to two giants
so two outs diamax will shift to the
left side of the infield here for
longoria
yoshimski at first base slater at third
with two outs
and there's a ground ball back up the
middle but fielding the ball rojas and
he'll throw to first for the out and
that will end the ending
carson kelly's going to be the pinch
hitter here batting for vote and he'll
stay in the game and catch
[Applause]
lifted out to left
dickerson coming in he dives and he
caught it
now dalton varshall
is uh up to the plate as they pinch
hitter for
lo castro
0-1 pitch ground ball right back to
tyler rogers he's got it a couple of
steps toward first flips the ball to
belt for the out and the ball game is
over